well denise and brian the gusty
conditions have been ramping up for the
past couple of hours now where we are is
near charleston 215 not too far from red
rock resort and spa and you can see that
the wind is already starting to move
some of the palm trees around here
pushing them around and we are expecting
the worst of the winds to pick up now
through about eight o'clock but the
gusts will stick around all night now we
are seeing gusts across the valley the
video that you're seeing is from the las
vegas strip where you can see palm trees
and street signs blowing in the wind
from the strip to henderson and west to
summerlin which is where we are the wind
is as i mentioned clearly picking up and
it's only only going to get worse again
we're expecting the winds to pick up
over the next couple of hours and then
stay throughout the night and they'll
last again through the whole night
tonight and as we start to get into the
strongest
hours for the wind there is concern
about cleanup and some damage out there
and sally jeremiah is live now with more
on that sally
arco a very active day when it came to
that wind and of course that blowing
dust now ambi energy crews have been
telling me that they've been prepping
for this day since late last week
and the energy started making plans for
this day this past weekend calls were
made with the company's emergency
response department some of those who
worked the day shift at mv energy are on
longer today while the night shift is
prepared with extra staff director of
grid operations scott kaufman says
they're used to this these are really
strong winds right we're really trying
to take the advice of all those weather
experts out there
if if gusts do do show up at 60 maybe
even 70 miles an hour
there could definitely be some impacts
some of the bigger concerns as we move
into tonight falling trees that will
bring down power poles if you see down
poles or wires stay at least 35 feet
away and call 911.
now out here live some of the ways you
can prepare by having batteries
flashlights and learning how to open
that garage door manually for now
reporting live sally jaramillo live
local now